dans les lois de programme depuis les
années 60 il y a eu deux manières de les
regarder soit c'est la courbe budgétaire
et les critères économiques et
financiers qui font le physique le
matériel l'entraînement la vie des
troupes
soit c'est la promesse du physique
le rapport annexé l'engagement du
ministre devant le Parlement qui fait
les ressources en fait est-ce qu'on
considère que les marches sont des
planchers ou des plafonds mais ça c'est
important peut-être de dire que ça
appellera des des débat aussi ou
amendements que sais-je sur cette
affaire là nous au moment où je vous
présente ce projet de loi monsieur
présent même monsieur la sénateur il est
clair que pour nous ce ne sont pas des
plafonds se sont forcément des planchers
sous lequel on ne doit pas aller j'en
veux pour prendre preuve le milliard
d'euros que nous vous avons proposé de
voter je vous en remercie l'année
dernière pour
des crédits de défense c'est à dire en
fait qu'on dit qu'elle est exécutée
exécutée à l'europrait cette
programmation actuelle en fait c'est
faux puisque en fait elle est
surexécutée déjà d'un milliard d'euros
et je vous proposerai un collectif
budgétaire on peut aller faire 1,5
milliards d'euros supplémentaires je me
suis déjà expliqué devant vous lu tanti
drone quelques effets d'inflation des
gros efforts sur les munitions et donc
on voit bien qu'on va vers une LPM qui
aura été surexécutée de 2,5 milliards
d'euros par rapport à ce qui était
programmé je dis pas ça pour qu'on nous
en remercie je dis juste que je veux
qu'on nous crédite de bonnes foi de
cette acceptation que les marches sont
des socles des planchers et non pas des
plafonds et ça veut dire qu'en 20223 là
en ce moment en dépit de l'inflation
très puissante et grave que nous
connaissons sur la pour le pays vous
n'avez aucun programme aucun équipement
militaire qui a pris du retard grâce
notamment à l'argent aussi qui a été
évidemment voté dans le cadre des
voitures rectificatives ou de discussion
que nous avons évidemment avec les
différents industriel